this is a serious storm and we urge all
those in the affected areas to heed
state and local authorities
stay safe and know that we'll be with
you every step of the way
to support rescue respond
and recover in the days and weeks ahead
that's what americans do that's vice
president mike pence who last night
delivered a message of support to those
in the path of this very
devastating hurricane laura the third
night of the republican national
convention
focused on the theme the land of heroes
and included speeches from military
veterans and police officers
now this comes as at least 500 members
of the national guard
were deployed in wisconsin overnight as
protests continue over the police
shooting of jacob blake
south carolina senator tim scott spoke
about president trump's agenda on racial
issues
during his rnc speech on monday and he
joins us this morning to discuss
senator scott it's good to see you again
you know last night
good to see you the uh the through line
seemed to be law and order
last night and they were talking about
in biden's america there will be no law
and order but here we sit
in the trump administration's law and
order and people could say
there's no law and order in the streets
do now how can they make the argument
when some people believe
that the president has contributed to
the chaos that we're seeing in the
streets
well i think that anyone that tries to
make what we're seeing
in minneapolis or now in kenosha into an
issue
with president trump would would not do
so
during the obama years when we had the
walter scott shooting or the dylan roof
shooting this is not a political issue
this is an issue of the heart
and this is an issue that we need to
solve we're looking at the video
looking at the video i saw no
justification whatsoever for those cops
to shoot that young man
jacob and so we need to get to the root
of the issue and as the pastor who
prayed
before the news conference for the
family said this is a sin
issue not a skin issue though it seems
to be happening
far more often to to folks who are
african-american than not
that frustrates me to be honest with you
gary that's why senator scott it's hard
to not say that it's a skin issue
you know you have to look at the tapes
last night
let me just hear me out for a second the
young white teenager
that had that that assault rifle who's
walking down the street
who the crowd is saying has just shot
black lives matter
protesters the police actually give him
a bottle of water
here is jacob black who is going into
his car
he is unarmed he does not have a weapon
on him at the time
the police officer is holding his shirt
he shot
seven times and is probably paralyzed
this keeps happening senator scott you
have written yourself about being
stopped
as a black man on capitol hill because
of the color of your skin how are you
processing this
as i said i was frustrated i know you're
more frustrated than i've been watching
you all morning so i know your
frustration
it's not frustration senator it's pain
it's pain
it's pain don't misunderstand
obviously i've been watching you and he
listening to you all morning so
it may be pain but it's also frustration
and frankly i think many of us should be
frustrated by what we see on the screens
if you're not frustrated i don't know
why
i certainly am frustrated by what i'm
seeing on the scene what i would say is
this though the reason why i said it's a
sin issue not a skin issue is am
quoting the pastor of the family who
spoke number one number two
uh the the incidents that we're seeing
around the country are not
new these are not new issues thank god
for video we're getting to see the
issues
for the first time and we're responding
it to responding to it
at a high higher level because we now
are having it reinforced by video
i think that is a terrible thing yet a
good thing because it's a good thing
because these have been the complaints
of african-americans
for generations now we're having a
chance to solve some of these issues
and that's one of the reasons why i'm
still at the table
working with karen bass and other
members of the cbc
on police reform because i believe we
can make a difference
working together to solve these problems
and if we do
that we'll see fewer of these incidents
we'll have more training more police
more police cameras which will be very
helpful we'll have more de-escalation
training which will be helpful
we can save lives by not allowing the
issue
of police reform to become a political
issue it has to be an issue
where people of good intention come
together
and solve problems so that you and i
will be less frustrated
when we're talking to each other on cps
this morning yes i actually look forward
to that day we keep hearing you know
it's a couple of bad apples
you know last time i checked an apple
never killed anybody it really is time
to have a real
frank conversation in this country black
white democrat and republican
about what we need to do about policing
in this country and i know that you have
tried i know that you have tried and you
you put you i'm not presented okay i'm
glad to hear that
let's talk about the conditions let's
talk about your convention tonight
what do you expect to hear from the
president this evening what do you think
we all need to hear
well i hope he starts with kenosha and
the hurricane
these are two major incidents or issues
that are
overwhelming good people throughout this
country and our focus and our attention
is there and i think he has to touch on
the pandemic as well
but i hope that he also looks to our
future and talks about
bringing this nation together and making
sure that we return
to the pre-covet 19 economic success
and social cohesion if we hear those
messages
i think we'll be in in good stead for
what we hope to see
in october which is the race closing and
becoming more competitive
that's the kind of performance that we
need to see i think the first lady did a
very good job
of talking about learning from people
who are not like you
that tone that she set i hope is
mimicked or followed should i say
by the president you know i think uh
melania trump did an excellent job in
bringing in
and trying to unite the country do you
think the president is capable and i
asked the senator scott
with all due respect because one of the
first speakers he had that night
was the white suburban couple who held a
gun on
unarmed black protesters and then it
it's sort of uh
laying down the foundation that you are
not safe in the suburbs
because you will have marauding people
going in the suburbs taking over the
suburbs do you think
that white people are not safe in the
suburbs because that seems to be the
message
that is being not so subtly put out into
the
ether during this time
yes uh you asked two questions in two
different areas number one
are they the same i know you can
multitask i know you can handle them
go ahead i'm just excited that you have
so much confidence in me thank you very
much
first i would say there's no doubt that
the suburbs are
are safe number one number two can the
president deliver on the message the
answer is yes
the truth is that we have made
tremendous strides in the right
direction
and i hope that we continue to do so
i've often quoted the quota from
john lewis my good friend who told me as
a young rookie
to never let bitterness overwhelm my
life because it poisons me
not the people that i'm focused on and
so
i think it's really important for us to
remember that today and every day and
frankly
his approach to non-violent protests is
one of the reasons why
i'm able to be a united states senator
today because he paid such a high price
i hope that we remember the heroes of
america
to not not to put them to the side but
right now we need to
crystallize and focus on moving forward
and confronting those issues and those
people who are in the way if we do both
we'll have a better america tomorrow
than we have today nba players announced
yesterday they're going to boycott they
boycotted the games last night they're
having meeting this morning quickly do
you support that boycott
well listen i think it's a non-violent
boycott sterling brown personally had
some interactions that were very unfair
i think that you can't expect them to do
anything other than
to be heard you can look back at
muhammad ali or the 1960s with our
olympic heroes
raise their hands there's a way to do it
in a non-violent way
for those like me who don't want
violence this is one of the ways that
they can do it you don't have to agree
with it but it certainly is a
non-violent protest
senator scott thank you we should also
say nobody i know wants violence or
looting nobody
thank you very much for joining us today
you have a great day i know i'll see you
again